good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
and this is the Ingram angle Prince
Harry Johnny Depp will they take a
starring role and it can't miss seeing
an unseen with Raymond Arroyo at head
but first Joe tries to feel our pain
a White House fresh out of ideas is
casting about for ways to save both
Biden and the Democrats in Congress now
no matter how much they've tinkered with
their messaging we've talked about this
Americans just aren't buying what
they're selling
now the Press is even issuing dire
assessments
Biden is at or near he's low ebb in
terms of job approval during his term in
CNN's latest poll of polls his approval
rating is at just 39 percent
now Biden didn't have a lot of Goodwill
left with the public before this week
but the conflicting messages coming out
of the White House and the broader
Democratic party make it look like there
is no plan to turn things around in
advance of the midterm elections which
are now just over 200 days off that was
click Chris saliza
and given that the Democrats refuse by
the way to change their policies on
energy and the border that have made
them so unpopular what can Joe do well
he can pretend he feels your pain
because he was poor too once
I grew up in a household where we lived
in a split level home three bedrooms
four kids mom and dad and Grandpa
delivered us I was listed I was had the
great pleasure of being listed as the
poorest man in Congress for 36 years I
still had making a hell of a lot more
money anybody else because I was getting
a senator's salary
no kidding I didn't think you should
make money while you're in office then
to drive home the poverty point to drive
home the poverty point he followed it up
with an early morning tweet today saying
I know that families are still
struggling with higher prices I grew up
in a family with the price of gas went
up we felt it
now
let me understand this
the White House believes that the
families seeing their savings eroded by
inflation
they're seeing their neighborhoods
engulfed by violent crime they're going
to feel better now because Joe claims
empathy that's carried over from
experiences several decades ago
all right Joe's lived high on the hog
for years now we all know that remember
just last week when we learned that
according to text on Hunter's old laptop
that Joe's nerdwell son was covering
expenses for the family
one January 2019 text to his sister
Naomi saying I hope you all can do what
I did and pay for everything for this
entire family for 30 years 30 years
it's really hard but don't worry unlike
pop I won't make you give me half your
salary
30 years three decades now that would
cover a significant stretch of Biden's
Senate career you know when he was the
poorest member
now this is where we should remind you
that throughout the campaign Joe groust
at the mere mention of any impropriety
as it related to Hunter
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas
business I have never discussed with my
son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period what's your
understanding of what your son was doing
for an extraordinary amount of money I
don't know what he was doing
now look anyone who's had some success
and now who has grown kids
we know they worry more about their
children than about themselves
so helping Hunter is by far the best way
to influence Joe because Joe worries
more about Hunter than he does about
himself that's what you do when you're a
parent
the fact that so many people in
Washington refuse to admit this obvious
fact shows that our establishment
believes it's okay for politicians to
use their offices to enrich their
families
but of course that all makes sense to
Democrats
meanwhile as Joe convened a big confab
with this foreign policy team tonight he
wants you to think that he's a man for
all seasons that he'll lead the world
out of the current morass it's in
but unless that begins with redoubling
our efforts to take on China well the
rest is all Bluster
and remember why their inability to
confront China is significant as it
relates to the Biden schemes documents
unveiled two weeks ago by Senators Ron
Johnson and Chuck Grassley showed that
Hunter and Joe's brother Jim receive
monthly payments of a hundred thousand
dollars and sixty five thousand dollars
respectively as part of an August 2017
Consulting agreement between Hunter and
guanguin Dong a top official at the CCP
linked Energy company
well the documents also indicate that
Jim Biden's company received payments
directly from a company jointly owned at
the time by Hunter Biden's Law Firm now
the takeaways here are undeniable
Biden's Focus if he's capable of any
focus at all
is enriching his family as much as
possible before he leaves this Earth
this will require capitulation to China
and to the American left and so far he's
doing both
profiting off Joe's stint in the Senate
his eight years as vice president and
even now when he's president
it's just what the bidens do
and now as the bidens enjoy the rewards
of their dirty family influence business
Americans themselves they're suffering
under Joe's bumbling careless watch
and I'm telling you this tonight no
attempt at play acting the role of an
empathetic character is going to make it
feel any more pleasant or Joe any more
popular hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else